BUT FIRST, THE KIDS STILL AREN’T
ALL RIGHT AND THAT’S THE FOCUS
OF TONIGHT’S ANGLE.
>> THESE CHILDREN ARE THE KITE
STRINGS THAT LIFT OUR NATIONAL
AMBITIONS ALOFT, AND HOW WE
TREAT THEM IS THE MAJOR OF WHAT
KIND OF DECENCY AND HONOR WE
HAVE AS A SOCIETY.
>> WE ALSO WANT THAT FUTURE TO
BE BETTER FOR OUR CHILDREN, SO
THIS IS ALL ABOUT THE CHILDREN.
>> Laura: FOR DECADES
DEMOCRATS HAVE TRIED TO CONVINCE
WOMEN THAT THEY CARED MORE ABOUT
THEM AND THE CHILDREN THAN THE
REPUBLICANS CARE.
IT’S TEDIOUS CLICHES AND SUPPORT
FOR THINGS LIKE ABORTION AND
FOOD STAMPS.
MEANWHILE, REPUBLICANS THINK
WOMEN VALUE THINGS LIKE I DON’T
KNOW, FROM ECONOMIC PROSPERITY,
A GOOD JOB INTO SAFE STREETS.
BUT THAT’S NOT ALL.
MOTHERS AND FATHERS OF COURSE
ALSO GREATLY VALUE EDUCATION AND
ANYONE WHO HAS OR HAS HAD
CHILDREN KNOWS THERE IS NO
SUBSTITUTE FOR INTEREST IN
LEARNING FROM TEACHERS IN AN
ACTUAL SCHOOL WITH PEERS AND
ACTUAL CURRICULAR ACTIVITIES.
>> THE KIDS IN MY CLASSROOM ARE
ALL LAUGHING AND TALKING AND
THEY ARE BUSY AND THERE’S
MOVEMENT AND I’VE GOTTEN THAT
FROM A TOTALLY DIFFERENT THING
WHERE I’M AN I.T. PERSON LOOKING
AT A SCREEN ALL DAY.
>> IT’S IMPORTANT TO FOCUS ON
SAFETY BUT THERE IS AN ESSENTIAL
BUSINESS THAT HAS TO GET WORK
DONE AND WE THINK EDUCATING OUR
KIDS IS ESSENTIAL.
>> Laura: THUS, AFTER THREE
AND A HALF MONTHS OF DISTANCE
LEARNING, DON’T YOU HATE THAT
PHRASE?
FOR MILLIONS OF STUDENTS,
EXHAUSTED PARENTS COAST-TO-COAST
AND ESPECIALLY MOTHERS ARE
ANXIOUS ABOUT WITH THE FALL WILL
BRING FOR THEIR CHILDREN AND
THEMSELVES.
AS MOMS WHO WORK OUTSIDE THE
HOME ARE BEGINNING TO HEAD BACK
INTO THE OFFICE, THEY NEED TO
KNOW THAT THEIR SONS AND
DAUGHTERS WILL BE HEADING BACK
TO SCHOOL MONDAY THROUGH FRIDAY.
YOU KNOW, LIKE THEY DID IN THE
PC ERA, PRECOBIT COVID.
IN ONE OF THE MOST AFFLUENT
SUBURBS OF WASHINGTON, D.C., THE
DEMOCRAT-CONTROLLED SCHOOL
DISTRICT MADE THE SHOCKING
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT IT’S NOT GOING
TO BE FULLY REOPENING THE FALL.
INSTEAD FAMILIES ARE GIVEN TWO
OPTIONS.
ENROLLING THEIR KIDS AND 100%
ONLINE CLASSES FOUR DAYS PER
WEEK OR IN PERSON CLASSES WERE
JUST TWO DAYS A WEEK.
WITH THE LATTER OPTION KIDS WHAT
WOULD HAVE TO REMAIN 6 FEET
APART AT ALL TIMES, DAILY HEALTH
SCREENINGS AND REGULAR HAND
WASHING AND SANITIZING.
IT’S SIMILAR TO A PLAN BEING PUT
FORWARD TO THE NEIGHBORING
LOUDOUN COUNTY VIRGINIA, UNDER
THEIR WEALTHY COUNTY CONTROLLED
BY DEMOCRATS.
WE HAVE A LOT OF THOSE IN THE
D.C. AREA, I WONDER WHY.
NOW PARENTS IN BOTH COUNTIES ARE
RIGHTFULLY OUTRAGED.
ONE PARENT TELLING THE LOCAL ABC
STATION, I ALSO HAVE SEEN THE
REPERCUSSIONS AT HOME WHERE THEY
WERE DISTANCING.
I SAW DEPRESSION.
I SAW THEM LOSE INTEREST IN LIFE
AND I CAN’T SIT BY AND WATCH
THAT HAPPEN AGAIN.
SHE IS RIGHT.
WE CAN’T LET THIS HAPPEN AGAIN.
WE KNOW THE HEAVY TOLL THIS IS
TAKING ON CHILDREN’S MENTAL
HEALTH.
>> THE VAST MAJORITY OF CHILDREN
ARE VERY, VERY LOW RISK OF ANY
SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES OF THIS
DISEASE.
KEEPING KIDS OUT OF SCHOOL IS
CAUSING ENORMOUS HARM TO THEM.
WE KNOW SOME STUDIES NOW OUT OF
CHINA THAT DEPRESSION RATES IN
KIDS WHO HAVE BEEN LOCKED DOWN
OR UP TO 20-30%.
WE KNOW THE CHILDREN FROM LOW
INCOME FAMILIES IN PARTICULAR OR
BEING HOMESCHOOLED, IF WE ARE
WAITING FOR TILDEN TO BE
IMMUNIZED BEFORE THEY GO BACK TO
SCHOOL, WE COULD BE LOOKING AT
TWO, THREE, OR FOUR YEARS,
THAT’S AN ETERNITY.
>> Laura: NOW OF COURSE LIVING
IN THIS AREA WE ARE USED TO
MISTAKES, AND IT WOULD BE A
TERRIBLE, TERRIBLE SHAME.
IF THESE TWO COUNTIES SET AN
EXAMPLE FOR THE REST OF AMERICA.
NOW I AM SURE THE FOLKS IN
FAIRFAX COUNTY ARE CLAIMING THEY
ARE ONLY DOING THESE EXTREME
MEASURES BECAUSE OF THE VIRUS,
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH.
BUT THAT IS JUST ABSURD.
THERE IS NO SCIENCE THAT
SUPPORTS KEEPING KIDS ESPECIALLY
THOSE IN THE YOUNGER GRADES AWAY
FROM THE CLASSROOM.
NPR REPORTED YESTERDAY THAT
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC BOTH THE
YMCA AND OF THE NEW YORK CITY
EDUCATION DEPARTMENT KEPT
CHILD CARE CENTERS OPEN FOR THE
CHILDREN OF FRONT-LINE WORKERS.
THEY COLLECTIVELY TOOK CARE OF
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF KIDS FOR
MONTHS.
SO GUESS HOW MANY COVID
OUTBREAKS WERE LINKED TO THEM
STAYING OPEN?
ZERO.
FURTHERMORE A SURVEY BY BROWN
UNIVERSITY ECONOMIST FOUND THAT
JUST .16% OF THE 20,000 CHILDREN
AT 916 CARE CENTERS ACROSS THE
COUNTY WERE COVID POSITIVE.
.16.
THE EVIDENCE FOR REOPENING OUR
SCHOOLS IS OVERWHELMING.
ELLIOTT HASKELL, A POLICY EXPERT
WITH THE ROBINS FOUNDATION
SAYING THERE ARE ALMOST NO
RECORDED CASES OF CHILD TO ADULT
TRANSMISSION OF COVID-19.
IT’S NOT A ZERO RISK BUT WE ARE
ACTING WITH THE MARCH 2020
UNDERSTANDING OF COVID-19 AND
NOT WITH THE 2020 -- JUNE 2020
UNDERSTANDING.
LET’S SEE HOW THE EUROPEANS ARE
HANDLING THIS DECISION.
EUROPEAN COUNTRIES THAT HAD FAR
HIGHER COVID DEATH RATES THAN WE
DID SUCH AS FRANCE AND BELGIUM
HAVE ALREADY SENT STUDENTS BACK
TO SCHOOL.
ITALY AND SPAIN ARE REOPENING
SCHOOLS IN SEPTEMBER AND OF
COURSE SWEET AND NEVER CLOSED TO
SOLAR SCHOOLS AT ALL.
NO SIGNIFICANT OUTBREAKS IN
THESE COUNTRIES HAVE BEEN
REPORTED DUE TO SCHOOL
ATTENDANCE.
UNFORTUNATELY FAIRFAX COUNTY
ISN’T LISTENING.
THE STUDENT BODY IN FAIRFAX
HAPPENS TO BE ONE OF THE MOST
DIVERSE IN AMERICA.
26% OF HISPANIC, 8%
AFRICAN-AMERICAN, 23% ASIAN AND
33% WHITE.
THOUSANDS OF THESE PARENTS ARE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND OTHERS
LIVE PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK.
AND THERE ARE OTHERS WHO ARE
WEALTHY OF COURSE.
BUT WHAT ARE THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
LESS ADVANTAGE SUPPOSED TO DO
HERE?
HOW IS NOT GOING TO WORK?
ARE WOMEN, WHO DEMOCRATS CARE SO
MUCH ABOUT, ARE THEY GOING TO
HAVE TO QUIT THEIR JOBS TO
HOMESCHOOL THEIR KIDS?
HOW CAN GOVERNOR RALPH NORTHAM
COUNTENANCED THIS AND HOW ARE
THE TEACHERS UNIONS DRIVING
THESE DECISIONS?
THE ANSWER TO THE LAST TWO
QUESTIONS IS LIKELY, A LOT.
KEEP THE CHAOS GOING THROUGH THE
FALL IN THE STREETS AND IN THE
HOMES.
IT WILL BE TERRIBLE FOR THE
LARGER ECONOMY, TERRIBLE FOR THE
UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS IN GOD
AWFUL FOR STUDENTS.
NOT A GOOD SITUATION FOR ANY
INCUMBENT PRESIDENT.
POLITICS IS ALREADY POISONED THE
SCHOOL CURRICULA ACROSS AMERICA.
PROPAGANDA FROM THE 1619 PROJECT
ALREADY SEEPING INTO HISTORY
CLASSES, WE TALKED ABOUT THAT
LAST WEEK.
SENSIBLE SCHOOL CHOICE
INITIATIVES ARE BLOCKED BY
DEMOCRATS.
THEY TRAP AT MINORITY KIDS IN
UNDERPERFORMING SCHOOLS.
BUT POLITICS SHOULD NEVER AFFECT
WHETHER SCHOOLS OPEN FOR REGULAR
CLASSES.
IN THE COMING DAYS AND WEEKS
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS AMERICA
WILL BE ANNOUNCING THEIR
DECISIONS ON SCHEDULES AND
CLASSROOM LEARNING.
MOTHERS AND FATHERS MAKE THEIR
VOICES HEARD ON THIS LOUD AND
CLEAR.
OUR KIDS NEED TO BE BACK IN
SCHOOL.
WIDESPREAD CLOSURES WILL HAVE
TERRIBLE LONG-TERM CONSEQUENCES
FOR OUR CHILDREN AND WILL DO
LITTLE, IF ANYTHING, TO STOP
COVID-19.
THINGS LIKE HAND SANITIZING
STATIONS AND EVEN TEMPERATURE
CHECKS AT THE DOOR COULD EASILY
BE INCREMENTED WITHOUT THROWING
MILLIONS OF AMERICAN FAMILIES
INTO CHAOS.
IF PARENTS WANT TO KEEP THEIR
KIDS AT HOME THEY SHOULD HAVE
THE OPTION AND THEY SHOULD BE
ABLE TO DO THAT.
BUT THE VAST MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS DON’T HAVE THE LUXURY
TO QUIT THEIR JOBS OR THE SKILL
AND PATIENCE REQUIRED TO TEACH
THEIR KIDS AT HOME LET ALONE
MULTIPLE CHILDREN IN DIFFERENT
GRADES.
NOW IF ALREADY STRESSED OUT
PARENTS AND ISOLATED CHILDREN
ARE FORCED BACK INTO THE
SITUATION AGAIN, THE ONE THEY
JUST GOT OUT OF FROM THE SPRING,
EXPECT A DIFFICULT SITUATION TO
GET WORSE, DRAMATICALLY.
SO PELOSI REALLY CARES ABOUT THE
CHILDREN.
THEN WHY HASN’T SHE SPOKEN OUT
ABOUT THIS?
AND ASSUMING BIDEN EVEN
UNDERSTANDS WHAT’S HAPPENING
HERE, WHY ISN’T HE PUSHING FOR A
SAFE AND SENSIBLE REOPENING AS
WELL?
REMEMBER.
THIS IS TIME FOR LIBERALS TO
PRESS THEIR ADVANTAGE, TO
EXPERIMENT IN TERMS OF HOW MUCH
THEY CAN PUSH YOU AND HOW MUCH
SHE WILL TAKE, HOW RADICALLY
THEY CAN CHANGE THE OLD NORMAL
TO PREPARE YOU FOR THEIR NEW
NORMAL.
SO IT’S UP TO US TO CONSERVE AND
PRESERVE WHAT WE KNOW WORKS.